paramedic dina has been attacked
verbally sexually and physically all
while doing her job
but last year she was lucky to survive
when she went with emergency service
colleagues to check on a patient
first knife went into my chest on my
right side and the second knife which
was the much larger knife went into my
upper left chest
and i stumbled backwards
and then my colleague nick jumped in
front of me
and he pushed me out of the way to
protect me to stand in front of me and
he got stabbed in the back
dina and mick are back on duty but many
can't return
in 2019 pc andrew harper was killed
trying to stop a quad bike being stolen
there's a body in the road bobby in the
road just fell out of the vehicle
the teenagers responsible were sentenced
to between 16 and 13 years in prison
now andrew's widow lissy has the backing
of the prime minister for harper's law
mandatory life sentences for those who
kill emergency service workers while on
duty
i think it sends a message to those who
lead those sorts of lives who commit
crimes who have no remorse for for
taking innocent people's lives away and
it will tell them that we won't stand
for this
in the west midlands alone one ambulance
worker is physically assaulted every
single day and whilst most people
respect the essential job they do
this new law could mean that their cases
are treated differently to everybody
else's
the law change may restrict the role of
judges
according to some barristers
sentencing
by public opinion or by parliament
preventing
judges imposing certain sentences in
certain circumstances
is to my mind a rather slippery slope
for us to be going down
for those on the front line this is what
it's come to ambulance workers trialling
stab proof vests they welcome anything
that could give them greater protection
lisa dowd sky news wolverhampton